Es realmente increíble.
Manoush Zomorodi: Totalmente increíble, ¿verdad?
Así que este es mi cerebro en una resonancia magnética funcional,
y aprendí que en el modo predeterminado es cuando conectamos ideas dispares,
resolvemos algunos de nuestros problemas más molestos,
y hacemos algo llamado "planificación autobiográfica".
Es al mirar hacia atrás en nuestras vidas,
que notamos los grandes momentos, creamos una narración personal,
y luego establecemos metas
y averiguamos qué pasos debemos dar para llegar a ellos.
Pero ahora también nos relajamos en el sofá mientras actualizamos
un documento de Google Docs o respondemos un correo electrónico.
Lo llamamos "hacer lo que hay que hacer",
pero esto lo que dice el neurocientífico Dr. Daniel Levitin
que estamos haciendo.
(Audio) Dr. Daniel Levitin: Cada vez que cambias tu atención
de una cosa a otra,
el cerebro tiene que participar en un cambio neuroquímico
que usa nutrientes en el cerebro para lograrlo.
Y, si intentas hacer varias cosas a la vez,
ya sabes, hacer cuatro o cinco cosas a la vez,
no estás haciendo cuatro o cinco cosas a la vez,
porque el cerebro no funciona de esa manera.
En cambio, estás cambiando rápidamente de una cosa a otra,
agotando los recursos neuronales sobre la marcha.
(Audio) MZ: Y al cambiar y cambiar, estás usando glucosa, glucosa, glucosa.
(Audio) DL: Exactamente, y tenemos un suministro limitado de esas cosas.
MZ: Desde hace una década cambiamos nuestra atención en el trabajo
cada tres minutos.
Ahora lo hacemos cada 45 segundos,
y lo hacemos todo el día.
La persona promedio revisa el correo electrónico 74 veces al día,
y cambia tareas en su computadora
566 veces al día.
Descubrí todo esto hablando con la profesora de informática,
Dra. Gloria Mark.
(Audio) Dra. Gloria Mark: Vemos que cuando las personas están estresadas,
tienden a cambiar su atención más rápidamente.
También encontramos, curiosamente,
que cuantas menos horas de sueño tiene una persona,
es más probable que revise Facebook.
Así que estamos en este círculo vicioso y habitual.
MZ: ¿Pero podría romperse este ciclo?
¿Qué pasaría si rompiéramos este círculo vicioso?
Quizás mis oyentes podrían ayudarme a descubrirlo.
¿Qué pasaría si recuperamos esas fracturas en nuestros días?
¿Podría ayudarnos a poner en marcha nuestra creatividad?
Llamamos al proyecto "Aburrido y brillante".
Y esperaba que se unieran un par de cientos de personas,
pero comenzaron a registrarse miles de personas.
Y me dijeron que la razón por la que lo hacían
era por su preocupación por la relación con el teléfono,
que se habían hecho un poco... "codependientes", digamos,
(Audio) Hombre: la relación entre un bebé y su oso de peluche
o un bebé y su chupete
o un bebé que quiere el regazo de su madre
cuando lo sostiene en sus brazos un extraño,
(Risas)
esa es la relación entre mi teléfono y yo.
(Audio) Mujer: pienso en mi teléfono como una herramienta eléctrica:
extremadamente útil, pero peligrosa, si no la manejo adecuadamente.
(Audio) Mujer 2: Si no le presto mucha atención,
de repente me doy cuenta de que he perdido una hora
haciendo algo totalmente irracional.
MZ: Pero para medir realmente cualquier mejora,
necesitamos datos, ¿verdad?
Porque eso es lo que hacemos en estos días.
Así que usamos aplicaciones que midieron cuánto tiempo
pasamos todos los días en nuestro teléfono.
Si piensan que es irónico
que pidiera a las personas que descargaran otra aplicación
para pasar menos tiempo en sus teléfonos,
sí, es así, pero una tiene que saber dónde está la gente.
(Risas)
Antes de la semana del desafío,
teníamos un promedio de dos horas al día en nuestros teléfonos
y 60 recolecciones,
como un chequeo rápido, ¿recibí un nuevo correo electrónico?
Esto es lo que Tina, una estudiante de Bard College,
descubrió sobre ella misma.
(Audio) Tina: Hasta ahora, he estado pasando
entre 150 y 200 minutos en mi teléfono al día,
y he mirado mi teléfono de 70 a 100 veces por día.
Y es realmente preocupante,
porque es mucho tiempo que podría haber pasado
haciendo algo más productivo, más creativo, más por mí,
porque cuando estoy con mi teléfono, no estoy haciendo nada importante.
MZ: Al igual que Tina, la gente empezaba a observar su propio comportamiento.
Se estaban preparando para la semana del desafío.
Y ese lunes,
se despertaron con las instrucciones en su bandeja de entrada,
un experimento para probar.
Día uno:
"Ponlo en tu bolsillo".
Saca ese teléfono de tu mano.
Intenta eliminar el acto reflejo de controlarlo todo el día,
solo durante un día.
Y si esto suena fácil,
Uds. no lo has intentado.
Aquí está la oyente Amanda Itzko.
(Audio) Amanda Itzko: Estoy muy ansiosa.
me siento un poco trastornada,
porque me he dado cuenta de que miro mi teléfono
cuando voy de una habitación a otra,
al subir al ascensor,
e incluso, y esta es la parte de la que estoy realmente avergonzada
de decir en voz alta,
también en el auto.
MZ: ¡Caray!
Sí, pero como Amanda aprendió,
esta sensación de picor no es realmente su culpa.
La tecnología se diseñó para lograr ese comportamiento.
(Risas)
¿Verdad?
Aquí está el exdiseñador de Google, Tristan Harris.
(Audio) Tristan Harris: si estoy en Facebook, en Netflix o en Snapchat,
tengo literalmente mil ingenieros
cuyo trabajo es obtener más atención de ti.
Soy muy bueno en esto,
y no quiero que tú te detengas nunca.
¿Sabes lo que el CEO de Netflix dijo hace poco?
"Nuestros mayores competidores son Facebook, YouTube y el sueño".
Quiero decir, hay un millón de lugares para poner atención,
pero hay una guerra por conseguir esa atención".
MZ: Es decir, Uds. conocen ese sentimiento:
ese increíble episodio de "Transparente" termina,
y luego el siguiente comienza,
así que uno piensa, está bien, me quedaré despierto y lo veré.
O la barra de progreso de LinkedIn dice que están muy cerca
de tener el perfil perfecto,
para que agreguen más información personal.
Como me dijo un diseñador de UX,
las únicas personas que se refieren a sus clientes como "usuarios"
son traficantes de drogas y tecnólogos.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Y los usuarios, como sabemos, valen mucho dinero.
Aquí está el exgerente de Facebook y escritor,
Antonio García Martínez.
(Audio) Antonio García Martínez: Si algún producto es gratis
entonces tú eres el producto; tu atención es el producto.
Pero, ¿qué valor tiene tu atención?
Por eso, literalmente, cada vez que carga una página,
no solo en Facebook, en cualquier aplicación,
hay una subasta realizada al instante, millones de veces al día,
para exactamente cuánto costó esa impresión de anuncio.
MZ: Por cierto, la persona promedio pasará dos años de su vida
en Facebook.
Volvamos a la semana del desafío.
Inmediatamente, vimos un poco de creatividad.
Aquí está la neoyorquina Lisa Alpert.
(Audio) Lisa Alpert: Estaba aburrida, supongo.
Así que de repente miré la escalera que iba a la parte superior de la estación,
y pensé que
acababa de bajar esa escalera, pero que podía volver a subir
y luego bajé e hice un poco de cardio.
Así que lo hice,
y como tenía un poco más de tiempo, lo hice de nuevo y lo hice de nuevo,
y lo hice 10 veces.
E hice un entrenamiento de cardio completo.
Me subí al tren sintiéndome un poco exhausta,
pero, contenta, pues eso nunca se me había ocurrido.
¿Cómo es eso posible?
(Risas)
MZ: Y la creatividad significa diferentes cosas para diferentes personas.
Pero todos encontraron el desafío del tercer día más difícil.
Se llamó "Eliminar esa aplicación".
Selecciona esa aplicación
que siempre te atrapa, que te engancha,
elimínala de tu teléfono,
incluso solo por el día.
Eliminé el juego Two Dots y casi lloro.
(Risas)
Sí, los jugadores de Two Dots saben de lo que hablo.
Pero mi desgracia tenía buena compañía.
(Audio) Hombre 2: Este es Liam en Los Ángeles,
y eliminé Twitter, Facebook, Instagram, Tumblr, Snapchat y Vine
de mi teléfono
de un solo golpe.
Y fue una experiencia embarazosamente emotiva al principio.
Era extraño mirar esa pantalla
sin nuevas notificaciones.
Pero realmente me gustó decidirlo solo,
al pensar cuándo acceder a mis redes sociales,
y no dar a mi teléfono el poder de decidir eso por mí.
Así que gracias.
(Audio) Mujer 3: Eliminar la aplicación de Twitter fue muy triste,
y creo que tal vez, en el último año estando en Twitter,
he desarrollado una adicción a esto,
y este desafío "Aburrido y brillante" realmente me lo ha hecho ver.
Tras un breve período de sensación de abstinencia realmente horrible,
como la falta de cafeína,
ahora me siento estupenda.
Tuve una cena maravillosa con mi familia,
y espero continuar controlando el uso de estas poderosas herramientas.
(Audio) Mujer 4: No tengo esa sensación de culpabilidad
cuando sé que estoy perdiendo el tiempo en mi teléfono.
Quizá debería empezar a hacerme desafíos y recordatorios como este
cada mañana.
MZ: Quiero decir, sí, esto fue progreso.
No podía esperar ver lo que decían los números
al final de esa semana.
Pero cuando llegaron los datos,
resultó que habíamos reducido,
el promedio
solo a seis minutos,
de 120 minutos al día en nuestros teléfonos
a 114.
Sí. Lo logramos.
Así que volví a los científicos sintiéndome algo mal,
y solo se rieron de mí,
y dijeron, cambiar el comportamiento de las personas
en un período de tiempo tan corto
era ridículamente ambicioso,
y en realidad lo logrado está mucho más allá de lo que creíamos posible.
Porque más importantes que los números, eran las historias de las personas.
Se sintieron empoderados.
Sus teléfonos se habían transformado
de coordinadores de tareas
nuevamente en herramientas.
Y en realidad, lo que me sorprendió fueron lo que dijeron los jóvenes.
Algunos de ellos me dijeron
que no reconocieron algunas de las emociones
que sintieron durante la semana de desafío,
porque, si lo piensan,
si uno nunca ha conocido la vida sin conectividad,
es posible que uno nunca haya experimentado aburrimiento.
Y podría tener consecuencias.
Investigadores de la USC han descubierto que están estudiando adolescentes
que están en las redes sociales mientras hablan con sus amigos
o están haciendo los deberes,
y dos años después, son menos creativos e imaginativos
sobre su propio futuro personal
y sobre la resolución de problemas sociales, como la violencia en su barrio.
Y realmente necesitamos que esta próxima generación
se pueda enfocar en algunos grandes problemas:
cambio climático, disparidad económica,
diferencias culturales masivas.
No es de extrañar que los CEOs en una encuesta de IBM
identificaran la creatividad como la competencia de liderazgo número uno.
Aquí están las buenas noticias, a pesar de todo:
Al final, 20 000 personas participaron en "Aburrido y brillante" esa semana.
El 90 % redujo sus minutos.
El 70 % tuvo más tiempo para pensar.
La gente me dijo que dormían mejor.
Se sentían más felices.
Mi nota favorita fue de un tipo que dijo que sentía que se estaba despertando
de una hibernación mental.
Algunos datos personales y algo de neurociencia
nos dio paso para saber un poco más,
y un poco de aburrimiento nos dio algo de claridad
y ayudó a algunos de nosotros a establecer algunos objetivos.
Quiero decir, tal vez la conectividad constante
no será genial en un par de años.
Pero mientras tanto, enseñar a las personas, especialmente a los niños,
a usar la tecnología para mejorar sus vidas
y para autorregularse
debe ser parte de la alfabetización digital.
Así, la próxima vez que vayan a revisar su teléfono,
recuerden que si no deciden cómo van a usar la tecnología,
las plataformas decidirán por Uds.
Y pregúntense:
¿Qué estoy buscando realmente?
Porque si es para verificar el correo, está bien, háganlo y terminen.
Pero si es para distraerse de hacer el trabajo arduo
eso trae un pensamiento más profundo,
tómense un descanso,
miren por la ventana
y sepan que al no hacer nada
en realidad, están siendo más productivos y creativos.
Puede parecer extraño e incómodo al principio,
pero el aburrimiento realmente puede conducir a la brillantez.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)